The David Pakman show subreddit is a place
where more than 14,000 of our viewers and
listeners are regularly participating in respectful
and substantive political discussions. You
can find that at David pakman.com/reddit a
few posts from today that I want to call to
your attention, a user named the goat of goats.
Nine nine nine says wrong with a public option.
Don't most countries with universal healthcare
also allow private insurance. So this is a
very reasonable question and there's a couple
of things that are being mixed here. Uh, if
you have universal healthcare, it doesn't
necessarily follow that you make private insurance
illegal. In fact, I don't think that should
be a priority. Let private insurance exist.
If the, uh, nationalize the universal healthcare
system, medicare for all or whatever else
is good enough, people are going to prefer
it over private insurance and this will naturally
as the free marketers like to say it will
naturally do what needs to happen to private
insurance. A public option is something else
and studies have shown that public options
would only lower premiums by about seven to
8%, uh, which is marginal when it comes to
the total lack of affordability of health
insurance for so many people in this country.
So I think it's important to distinguish that
a public option is something that can exist
without having any kind of universal healthcare
or in addition to, and it is a separate question
from whether private for profit insurance
should be allowed to exist. Even if something
like Medicare for all is put in place. I happen
to think the answer is yes. Let it exist.
Don't go through the hassle of saying we are
going to make your business illegal things.
We'll just sort themselves out. If Medicare
for all or whatever government program is
put in place is good enough and people will
decide what it is that they prefer. Another
post from User Ryan Lynn Burgo, uh, about
New Mexico rolling out a plan for tuition
Free State College. I don't, we don't need
to analyze the proposal specifically, but
I think that on both single payer health care
and tuition and dealing with homelessness,
I am very much in favor of states piloting
programs on their own.
You will often hear a talking point from the
right on all of these social program proposals,
healthcare, whatever the case is that it would
not work in the United States. It works in
small European countries because they are
small and sometimes they say that it works
because the countries are homogenous. Although
it doesn't make any sense with regard to a
lot of these programs. A story for a different
day, I think it would be great for states
to pilot some of these programs. There are
many u s states with higher populations and
larger land masses than many European countries
and they would serve as great proving grounds.
Unfortunately, Vermont's single-payer attempt
did not end up happening. But I would love
to see New Mexico do a tuition free college.
I would love for any state to show the viability
of these programs and also the economic benefits
that they would bring with them.
A user on the subreddit named hollow brine
found the David Pakman show on tick tock.
Yeah. So listen, we, I like to sample different
platforms because you never know what could
be the next Instagram or the next big thing.
And we've tried things out on the show that
don't go anywhere and that's okay. We just
stop them and then we try something else.
And then some of the things we try work really
well. Youtube being one example, the show
Instagram page being another example. So after
reading a lot about this new platform called
tick-tock, we created a David Pakman show
account there. We've only posted one video
so far. We've only got like five followers
there so far. But I actually think there could
be something to this platform. And I like
to try to be an early adopter of a lot of
these things. So find us on tick tock.
Send me ideas about what we should even be
doing there. We're just learning about the
platform and figuring it out. Join the David
Pakman show subreddit@davidpakman.com slash
r e d d I t more than 14,000 of you already
have and a great source of political discussion,
respectful debate story ideas for the show.
Look forward to seeing you there.